today's question comes from Jose in
Texas should I cash in my whole life
insurance and get term insurance no you
should cash in your term you should get
term insurance and then cash in your
whole life insurance we approximately
$30,000 in cash value I'm sorry we're
both 64 years of age the agent is
suggesting a paid-up policy what is your
suggestion well the agent has a whole
life agent and so you know you don't let
the Fox in the henhouse and give you
advice on this so here's the thing you
have a savings element to a cash value
policy called cash value $30,000 you
have an insurance element which is the
life insurance that's paid if you die
the great ripoff of cash value life
insurances is that you will never get
both and you have paid for both you paid
extra for savings and you have life
insurance if you die they're gonna pay
the life insurance and they keep your
savings if you cash out the savings
they're gonna cancel your life insurance
now what is paid up insurance prepaid no
for paid
that's what paid up insurance is you can
pay up term life insurance if you want
to send them ten years of premiums in
advance they won't they won't send you
another bill for ten years it's magical
that's all this is
it's what paid up life insurance is
because you're as long as there's a
probability you're gonna die which if
you're breathing there's that
probability then there's a statistical
cost to covering your life and if the
cost is not the cost is never it never
goes away until you die and so the
insurance company is going to get their
freakin pound of flesh count on it
so paid up and overpaid and prepaid is
what paid up life insurance is so here's
the thing if you take $30,000 and you
put it into a mutual fund it made ten
percent that'd be three thousand dollars
a year
three thousand dollars a year would buy
you a term life insurance policy greater
than the one you have today if you're
healthy and could get the insurance and
they are paying you not three thousand
dollars on your thirty thousand dollars
they are paying you $300 on your thirty
thousand dollars about one percent not
10% so that's their gift to you is
they're giving you one percent of money
you should be making ten or twelve on
and in return they give you a free
policy it's kind of like when I was in
Sweden and they told me they had free
healthcare and I asked him what our tax
rate was and she said oh I pay 65
percent income tax and I said tell me
where the free starts if somebody takes
money out of one of your pockets and
then runs around behind your back and
drops it over your forehead does that
mean it's free this is stupid
okay that's this is how we think so okay
so it's not free and it's not paid up at
all
you're making a reduced rate of return
and they're using the difference to
provide you a toaster to go with your
new account you just opened if you're
old enough to remember that at the bank
okay so no it's not free there is you
know I got free interest no interest on
my new car which went down 62% in value
when I drove it across the curb you know
it ain't free dummy okay you have to
think through this stuff there is no
free sorry there's not I mean you get
free on the short term but somewhere
somehow it's being picked up so Jose you
get your term insurance if you need term
insurance is 64 years old you may not
need term insurance maybe you made a
bunch of other financial decisions that
were good ones and maybe you have some
money you might have I don't know what
you have well you manage seven or fifty
thousand dollars and no payments and the
kids are all grown and gone and if you
die she'd be okay you may not need life
insurance at all you may be self insured
because you've done a good job with your
money and you're out of debt and have
built some assets that would be the goal
with life insurance by the ways to get
out of the need from it you get away
from the need of it
don't have any need for it because
everybody that's left behind is okay
because you have money and until you
have that you buy life insurance I do
believe in term insurance so if you need
some insurance you get term insurance in
place then you drop the whole life never
drop insurance until you have the new
policy in place